dans cette banlieue pauvre de
port-au-prince il y à une école toute
neuve
les étudiants portent fièrement le nom
de l'acadien mark gallagher
même s'ils ne l'ont jamais rencontré il
connaît son histoire
en juillet 2009 le sergent gallagher
arrive en haïti
après une carrière comme porte parole de
la grc au nouveau vendu qui en nouvelle
écosse il rejoint alors les casques
bleus pour former la police locale
d'habitude on reçoit déjà connaître les
affaires policières le met en pratique
mais et les ballots ajouté na li pa
martin était jeudi est quelqu'un
sectionnelles qu'il était quelqu'un que
vous voulez et fait le travail en équipe
puis c'est le tremblement de terre mark
gallagher et parmi les victimes
ces images ont été tournées à l'endroit
où l'école mémoire de marque sera
construite
c'est un grand pas et on avait une
fondation écrit au nouveau produit qui
pour venir en aide à haïti et honorer la
mémoire du sergent décédé les amis de
mark gallagher vont amasser plus d'un
million de dollars en dons pour la
construction d'une école à rivière
froide le chaos
l'école ouvre cinq ans plus tard c'est
une école de métiers de bâtisseur 150
étudiants ils sont inscrits l'école se
donne une mission de construction mais
aussi une responsabilité sociale ça à la
fin de la sava et empêcher aux enfants
de faire des activités nocturnes
l'école va aider à relever la communauté
l'acadien qui voulait tellement faire du
bien dans le monde aura finalement gagné
son pari
mc gallagher vie au dedans de nous mêmes
vie aux deux dalles de chaque étudiant
de chaque professeur ici nicolas sanhes
bike radio canada à port-au-prince